[Music]
good morning goldie my name is guy
and i live in free city
i have everything i need
except one thing hey
excuse me
hey bud you ever think that there's got
to be more more than what
stuff we do day after day literally not
once
today's gonna be different goldie what
are we looking at
who are you we ran into each other the
other day how did you find me i waited
outside by the murder train guy
i have to tell you something there is no
easy way to say this this world
it's a video game
i really want to kiss you is that weird
listen to me you're not real
[Music]
wait you let who kiss you guy there's
not a button for that
oh he found the button
buddy if we're not real doesn't that
mean that nothing you do matters
i am sitting here with my best friend
trying to help him get through a tough
time now if that's not real
i don't know what it is millie i know
this world
is just a game but this place these
people that's all i have
thanks guy who is this guy this
character in the video game free city
has been turning heads
by being the good guy who is blue shirt
guy you're absolutely right who is he
or she indeed this loser is ruining the
game man
i don't care if he's arnold frickin
schwarzenbader
terminate him
we're doing great guy in two days the
game is gonna shut down
you this whole city they'll be gone what
if we can save it
[Music]
was that cool it felt really cool we can
change our world but we have to fight
together
i don't even know what's happening right
now but i love it this is the first time
i've ever driven a car before
i really wish you'd mentioned that yeah
[Music]
they seem nice